[Music]
well it is an honor to have you on the
uncommon ground podcast uh a lot of what
i'm trying to do
really been inspired by you oh my gosh
man that's
seriously
[Music]
but uh no man just the idea i mean you
kind of came out of nowhere this kind of
like comet of hope this kind of
supernova of solutions and really i
think had such a positive impact on the
2020 election and now you've written a
book i want to get into the book but
really i mean you've seen it all now you
were an entrepreneur
watching the
world go south for working-class people
you've been a not-for-profit leader now
you run for office national level local
level
i you know you should be depressed i
considered how tough these problems are
you've seen them all up close
how are you holding up
thanks for asking van
the presidential race was a journey that
i did try and catalog in the book and
then when that campaign ended it was
like a bit of
being one of those cartoon characters
who's been like running running and then
you're like off the cliff and you're
looking around being like
what's going on
uh and so that was a massive adjustment
and then i
ran for mayor
and that was an extraordinarily
difficult
race
uh and so coming off of that race
uh i definitely needed a little bit of
time with the family and
some sunshine in the summer
but the ideas i laid out in this book
uh are so needed right now and so
i feel really invigorated by the
possibility of getting these ideas out
because my journey through the
presidential race in particular
led me to
understand more fully why it feels like
we can't get anything done
and unfortunately we're being set up we
are being set up to not get much done
and there are all of these
people i feel like who are losing hope
right now
at the end of the day when what we're
going through right now it's a crisis of
the imagination i think it's a crisis of
human heart human soul like things are
changing so fast and i think change is
scary for a lot of people left and right
or otherwise and when you get scared you
get small when you get small you get
mean you get mean you start having a
self-fulfilling kind of experience where
other people start being mean to you and
you can wind up in a civil war in a
country if you're not careful i think
the biggest fear that people have is
that they're not gonna be able to feed
their families and so
people who've got good economic ideas i
think are really key and you've got some
in the book can you just talk a little
bit about how you see the economy what's
going wrong and how we can fix some of
it any of it the central problem is that
we've started to treat the capital e
economy as if it's its own goal
with its own heads
meanwhile our quality of life has eroded
to 28th in the world by
measurements like
clean air and clean water public
education
infant mortality life expectancy like
the basics
meanwhile the stock market is
gangbusters and everything else
and so i'm
a straightforward thinker where i'm
saying well you know if you are trying
to to
uh
increase stock market prices then i
guess that's what you're gonna get like
we should be trying to increase people's
uh life expectancy and education rates
and the quality of the environment and
if you made that the
measuring stick and the goal of progress
then all of a sudden every quarter you'd
have all like well we're still terrible
at this and then you know your public
officials would have a different set of
goals they'd be like oh well you know
28th that's pretty terrible let's try
and get up to 25th i i think that that's
true and at the same time
uh you know you got some pretty bright
answers the universal basic income idea
which is now well known but it wasn't
before you is that everybody should get
a thousand dollars period um and it's
just your money you do what you want you
that was a crazy idea but you have this
other idea that's kind of
you know really new and different which
is tax the robots why would taxing the
robots make a difference how's that even
gonna scratch the surface most people
never thought about that
more and more of the work that people
do
is going to be done by technology in the
days to come and our tax system right
now is going to do a terrible job of
capturing any of that value
where if you use google's ai to answer
phones there are two million americans
right now that are in call centers so
they pay taxes uh most most of them and
so
then you ask okay how much is google
going to pay in taxes if it's software
is doing this and the answer is next to
nothing you look at the tax rate of
these tech companies they just move it
through ireland or wherever the heck and
we don't see a dime so we're stuck in a
situation where
the value is going to be slipping
through our fingers more and more unless
we
actually capture a toll on that and if
we do capture a toll on that by the way
it could amount to hundreds of billions
of dollars trillions of dollars very
very quickly because the value's so
immense
and to me it points to a freshness of
approach that i think you represent i
think that both parties really need like
what you just said i don't think anybody
could argue with from the left or the
right if they thought about it there's
not an automatic constituency for or
against that that's already been trained
by their political media to hate it or
like it and you know which really kind
of brings me to the other point about
your book you know you're talking about
rewiring the government
i'm very worried about democracy me too
i don't like
what i'm seeing it seems to me
that
we now have
even at the level of voting
you have both sides
may be less and less willing to accept
the results of elections i think you've
popped a hood on that and you've got
some ideas as well that i think we're
talking about talk a little bit about
this idea of open primaries and rank
choice voting especially given that you
kind of had experience with that in new
york and you didn't win that election so
does it change your perspective on it i
mean how do you having actually thought
about it and argued for it and then
participated in it talk a little bit
about this idea of you know ranked
choice voting which they had in new york
well this to me is the recipe then right
now the approval rate for congress is 28
pretty low people aren't happy
the re-election rate for individual
members of congress is 92 percent like
almost guaranteed job security and the
there are two main reasons why
these numbers don't match very well
number one is that 83 percent of the
district races are safe seats it's going
to be either democrat or republican so
if you get to the general you win
and people can all think about their own
district it's probably a safe seat
so then the criteria to get reelected is
not somehow doing a great job for
your district it's can you get through a
party primary where only the most
partisan 11 to 20 will vote
and so that's why you have political
figures who don't want to compromise and
are willing to make very extreme
statements because
they're just worried about the most
extreme 20
in their district
uh but one community has actually made
this change where now it's open
primaries and right towards voting and
that state you're not going to believe
it everyone is alaska which last year
flipped a switch and said no more party
primaries
and then this year
senator lisa murkowski
was the only republican senator to vote
to impeach donald trump who's also up
for re-election
in 22.
her approval rating among republicans in
alaska right now is six percent
according to one poll so
if she was subject to a party primary
she's obviously out of there this is
which is one reason why you're not
seeing many republicans say a bad word
about trump
but now with open primaries uh and
ranked choice voting she actually
can make her case straight to all
alaskans and try and appeal to the 51
instead of the 10 to 20 at the extreme
so this is the big fix this is the
anti-polarization
recipe for the country
and believe it or not we don't even need
congress to do it that the way they did
in alaska was through a ballot
initiative that citizens led
we can just do the same in 24 other
states that allow for valve initiatives
and then unlock our legislators from
this extreme polarization that is
unfortunately driving them to the
extreme to keep their jobs
[Music]
you